the nintendo switch may have been the
old guy in the room this year when
compared to the ps5 and xbox series x
but the switch arguably stole the show
when it came to exclusive games in 2021
it's approaching its fifth birthday and
nintendo has shown no signs of slowing
down on its avalanche of games you can
only play on the hybrid console given
all of the standout exclusives that
landed on the switch this year it was
difficult to whittle down the list to
the best of the best but that's exactly
what's happened here here are gamespot's
picks for the 5 best nintendo switch
exclusives of 2021
metroid dread was the biggest surprise
of the year for the nintendo switch to
be clear it's not surprising that it's
great it's just kind of wild that it
exists at all nintendo tasked mercury
steam with unburying metroid dread it
cancelled nintendo ds project from its
grave nearly two decades after the last
brand new side-scrolling metroid
adventure was released while fans
continued to wait for metroid prime 4
dredd offered a welcome return to
side-scrolling action that many nintendo
fans grew up on metroid dread hit all
the right notes balancing open-ended
exploration with exciting boss battles
and tight platforming sequences dread
simply felt incredible in motion whether
you were roaming the varied locales in
search of missile packs or taking on
your old buddy crade in a fight to the
death while dread followed the familiar
metroid progression it added some new
wrinkles such as the emmy or killer
robots that samus had to evade brand new
suit powers and more hidden areas than
ever before metroid dread brought
samus's winding story arc to a fitting
and immensely satisfying conclusion in
our metroid dread review stephen petit
wrote more than anything else metroid
dread feels like going back to a place
of comfort after a long time away though
the gameplay is refined and new features
have been added to the mix dread sticks
closely to the formula of its
predecessors in the end for longtime
fans like myself that's probably for the
best
there's nothing to dread here we're home
again
while nintendo switch owners didn't have
the chance to play the monster hunter
game that catapulted the franchise to
mega stardom capcom more than made up
for that with monster hunter rise
arguably even more dynamic than monster
hunter world ryze added a wonderful new
mechanic that completely altered the
flow of both combat and exploration the
wire bug essentially a grappling hook
let hunters zip around the richly
detailed locales in a flash and made
showdowns with the larger-than-life
monsters more versatile in addition to
the wire bug ryze introduced the ability
to ride palomutes across the maps to
speed up the pace and get you into the
thick of the action quicker in this
respect monster hunter ryze felt more
action-packed by removing the tedium and
letting you focus on what monster hunter
is all about make no mistake monster
hunter ryze still offered a layered
action rpg experience featuring more
than a dozen weapons with unique styles
to master loads of customization
features and increasingly challenging
hunts to test your skills this time
round though monster hunter felt more
approachable than ever before the switch
console exclusive earned a 9 out of 10.
richard wakeling wrote going toe to toe
with these intimidating beasts is the
unmistakable core of the monster hunter
experience and ryze still feels like he
distinctly monster hunter game even if
it's more of a fully fledged action
title than any other entry in the series
this renewed focus doesn't diminish its
layered rpg mechanics nor does it dumb
down on any single aspect of the hunt
certain changes make ryze a more
approachable game for newcomers but you
also have the freedom to tailor the
experience to your liking
pokemon snap for nintendo 64 has long
been one of the most beloved pokemon
spin-offs more than 20 years after its
release nintendo finally brought it back
though the title is rather uninspired
new pokemon snap marked a triumphant and
charming return for the on rails shooter
a more tranquil pokemon experience new
pokemon snap let fans observe pokemon in
their natural habitats just like the
original and collecting research data
for the professor proved to be a
relaxing joy filled with surprises and
callbacks to the original game developer
bandai namco did a wonderful job with
the levels packing them with vibrant
colors and intricacies that brought the
world to life new pokemon snap also had
far more to offer than the original
thanks to a wide array of objectives to
complete that made replaying the dynamic
stages well worth your time adding the
ability to edit your photos to your
liking and create albums was a nice
touch and the sheer variety of pokemon
roaming the world nudged us to fill out
our collection much like our pokedex in
the mainline games in our new pokemon
snap review janae sitsis wrote fans
clamored for a pokemon snap remake for
years and with new pokemon snap we've
gotten more than we ever bargained for a
great sequel that pulls from all 8
generations of pokemon released so far
dynamic courses that can be explored
during both daytime and night time and
the ability to create an album of edited
personalized pokemon photos which you
can then print or post online a fitting
evolution of the game in the social
media era
after a long gap between titles the
fifth mainline shin megami tensei game
arrived on nintendo's switch this
holiday it's safe to say shin megami
tensei 5 was well worth the wait keeping
up with the traditions of the
long-running franchise shin megami
tensei 5 offered a deep and affecting
jrpg that kept us on our toes throughout
the entire duration of the lengthy
campaign while many jrpgs have a joyful
tone to them shin megami tensei 5 is
relentless in its approach to stick to
dark themes and a brooding atmosphere
its unique style extended to its
turn-based combat which provided some of
the toughest challenges of the year on
nintendo switch the brutal combat system
may have not always felt entirely fair
but there was no denying that it kept us
focused on thinking two steps ahead
despite its dark tones and challenging
combat scenarios shin megami tensor5
still managed to be the most inviting
entry in the series for newcomers due to
its fairly easy to follow story that
doesn't require any knowledge of
previous entries to enjoy with stunning
visuals a story and world that reacted
to your choices and a smartly designed
combat system shin megami tensor5 stood
out as the best jrpg on switch in 2021
in our shin megami tensei 5 review heidi
kemps wrote it's a game that demands a
lot of the player its slow pace and
punishing difficulty will more than
likely turn some folks off but those who
stick with it will find an incredibly
rewarding experience that only gets
better the further in you get shin
megami tensei 5 truly makes you feel
like the weight of this crumbling
conflict-torn world of mythological
nightmares rests firmly on your
shoulders but it's a burden you'll be
glad you chose to bear
[Music]
super mario 3d world certainly wasn't
the first wii u game to get a second
lease on life on nintendo's switch but
it was arguably the most impressive
considering how much it added to the
overall experience nintendo made some
welcome quality of life changes to 3d
world including faster movement speeds
for each character that made the
platforming snappier and a tad more
challenging super mario 3d world is
chock full of awesome content on its own
but this package also added an entirely
new mario experience bowser's fury took
cues from super mario odyssey and
classic mario level design to create an
open world take on the retired plumber's
charming adventures bowser's fury saw
mario team up with bowser jr to stop a
terrifyingly large and furious bowser
from stumping everyone and everything to
bits the open world setting contained a
bunch of gradually unlocking levels with
a unique set of objectives the pleasant
and bright island world was occasionally
disrupted by a dark storm and bowser
spewing fireballs at you while you
frantically tried to collect every last
one of the hundred cat shines plus you
could even travel by water on plessy's
back the package earned a 9 out of 10
and our review said put together super
mario 3d world plus bowser's fury is a
spectacular package super mario 3d world
is an absolute joy of classic
platforming excellence and this is the
best version of it thanks to some well
calibrated improvements
so there you have it gamespot's top 5
nintendo switch exclusives of 2021 we'll
be revealing our top five xbox pc and
playstation games too so make sure you
hit that subscribe button so you can
catch up on the best games of the year
and speaking of we also have a deep dive
into why death loop is our game of the
year thanks so much for watching
[Music]
you